hello everyone and welcome to Game seven
of the 2018 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Khurana six games have already been
played the result is 3 3 2 3 and now we
entered the second half of the match
cousin had the white pieces in the
previous game game but as we are now in
the second half of the match he will
have the white pieces once again so it's
very interesting will he once again
tried to challenge Carwin a spectral
defense or will he try to go for
something else before we check out this
very nice game now we do get we do have
a couple of photos or again compliments
of Nicky Riga so let's check him out
also I will use them as a photo
challenge who is the young gentleman
making the first move for Magnus Carlsen
you can see that Carson seems very happy
with himself and Caruana perhaps a
little bit worried but most likely not
too much as he already faced this move
in this world champ championship in game
2 also here we have a very nice photo of
Magnus cross and high-fiving the young
gentleman and also a very nice photo of
Khurana handshaking with the young
gentlemen and here we have a photo of
them shaking hands
it's a unlike for the couple of previous
games we don't have a diagonal handshake
it's a pretty regular handshake and over
them towering chief arbiter loss of
Schmidt of course that is not lost are
Schmidt but I do hope some of you got
the joke so let's check out this very
nice game like we said Carlson has again
a white pieces for the second time in a
second game in a row and he opens with
d4 we have nice to have six Knight to f3
d 5 c4 and d6 we transpose into the
Queens gambit declined and for the time
being we will be following the game that
was already played I was Game two of
this World Championship match the famous
Rudy 8 moved by Caruana and moved him
Knight to c3
Bishop to e7 Bishop to f4 with castles
now comes c3 c5 everything the same as
in game 2 d captures on c5 Bushell
captures on c5 we have Queen to c2
Knight to c6 a3 and Queen to a5 and this
is where
was really excited will we see a rope to
d1 and rook to d8 again and Carson
trying to refute this peculiar idea
Corona brought turtle World Chess
Championship match but unfortunately we
we did not get to see this happen here
Knights the d2 was played this is a
crossing the improvement in this game
and already we have a surprise for
Magnus as now of course the knight is
threatening to come to b3 where both the
Queen and the bishop would come under
attack then the the other night would
come to a4 would again a double attack
against the Queen and the bishop and so
on and here Corona plays Queen to d8 and
here Carlsen starts a spending time and
I believe he didn't really say it in
those exact words in the press
conference but it sounded to me as if he
was not prepared for Queen to d8 and
it's a very odd since there's a really
not all that much you can do here there
was a move he Cara Nakamura in the grand
grand Chester in Paris but it was a
rapid gameplay the bishop to be four
against Veselin Topalov and nakamura was
able to win this game but it it's not
like Bishop to b4 was a super super
troublesome move for white after pawn
captures pawn characters and the Knight
to b3 Catherine c3 was played with Czech
pawn captures and after Queen to d8 we
continue into this game where White has
an isolated and C pawn and the game
continued were Nakamura won a very nice
game but here Caruana actually just went
back with the Queen Queen to d8 and now
Knight to b3 does not come with a double
attack here Carlsen after spending some
10 minutes he decides to go for Knight
to b3 and again we have Bishop to b6 and
this is a move that was never played in
this position there are a couple of
moves our games in the database were
Bishop to e7 was played but
interestingly
or in all the games I found that Bishop
to e7 was played white won that game so
here an improvement by Caruana Bishop to
b6
Bishop to d6 would come as something
like pawn captures on d5 pawn captures
and after captures captures rook to d1
then black would have an isolated pawn
in the center and the white would just
try and keep it there it's very unlikely
that black will be able to push d4 at
any point and well black will basically
struggle to keep his deep on life for
the entire game so it seems like an
reasonable idea after this Knight to b3
Bishop to b6 by Caruana
but here as this move was never played
it's hard to say if Carson had anything
prepared for it and it seems not since
he spent ten minutes on Knight to b3 and
again he spends 13 minutes on this
Bishop to e2 move and a lot of a lot of
people were suggesting that the rook to
d1 is a better move and Carson was asked
at a press conference later perhaps did
he consider rook to d1 but he said that
he decided to go for the for the this
calm option of Bishop to e2 also there's
a very interesting choice maybe of going
g4 here but that could maybe be played
in a rapid or a blitz game because of
course white can look for something
black actually goes for this but black
and simply ignore even push d4 one of
the reasons why rook to d1 there was
perhaps a better move and now after you
Castle or or go rook to d1 let's see you
Castle queenside then e v is coming and
here black would really be better but
okay like we said much up to b6 cross
and goes Bishop to e2 and now we have
Queen to e7
carvanha simply gets his Queen away from
the D file as you know presumably all
the action will will happen along the D
file when it opens and here again a lot
of people were expecting rook to d1 but
Carson actually played Bishop to g5 and
he did spend against some 13 minutes and
Bishop to g5 but rook to d1 is again a
very interesting because after D
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
rook to d8 now you can Castle and now
after black attacks your Bishop wooden
eye to h5 it seems like you don't want
to allow such a move that's why Bishop
to g5 was perhaps better not allowing
the Knights this free move but you would
actually have rook captures an dat
check Queen captures rook to d1
attacking the Queen and now it doesn't
matter either the Queen will move or he
will block with the bishop but white
will get this Bishop to d6 move in and
whites dark square Bishop will be all
right here so perhaps one of the reasons
why magnus decided to go worship the g5
not to allow this free move but on the
other hand who knows we haven't heard
this particular idea in the press
conference Bishop to g5 was played and
then we have D captures on c4 on this
move or karana most likely didn't
calculate Bishop to g5 before Carson
actually played it so here Caruana took
30 minutes something over half an hour
to make this D captures on c4 move and
okay we have d captors on c4 and now
comes after some 14 minutes cross and
plays Knight to d2 which you kind of do
have to decide whether you want to
capture this immediately but if you
capture it immediately then you can run
into Knights to e5 it comes as an attack
on the bishop bishop moves and now h6
Bishop to h4 and now nice the g6
attacking the bishop and after Bishop to
g3 Bishop to c7 black would be perfectly
fine here but captures Queen captures
and after white castles surely white
White has nothing to to claim as
advantageous here so after this D
captures on c4 again Carson spends some
14 minutes for this knife to be to move
according to see say it is the correct
way to go to at least try and look for
some advantage and Carson would
definitely enjoy some advantage as this
is his second game is white after this
game there are only five more games left
in classical time formats where Corona
will have three White's and two blacks
and okay Knight to e5 if you try
something like h6 here for example h6
then white will capture for example a
bunch of characters on f6 Queen captures
on f6 and now after Knight chapters on
c4 attacking the bishop bishop moves
still it would be playable but decides
not to go for it
so instead after Knight - D - nice
the e5 is played and now comes castles
by Carlsen a very interesting move it's
interesting what happens if you try to
hurt to collect your gambit pawn right
away if you go Knight captures on c4
here then you get Knight captures and
after Bishop captures you will get Queen
to c5 attacking the undefended bishop on
c4 after Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on c4 Bishop to e5 getting the
bishop out of the way but now comes f6 a
very troublesome move Bishop moves and
now e5 will kind of lock this light
square Bishop out of the game for the
time being and on the other hand after
Knight captures on c4 if Knight captures
you could also decide not to capture for
example on c4 but for example Bishop
captures on f6 then you get knocked
captures on e3 a very nice in-between
move that now if you capture the black
queen
black will capture the white queen with
check so grabbing a pawn on the way so
here not to lose any points of white
would have to capture on h7 would check
King captures and now Marshall captures
on e7 Knight see to check King moves
Knight captures on a1 Bishop captures on
f8 and now after Bishop to d7 attacking
the bishop here the bishop will simply
move but all in all it will be a better
position for black so after 95 you can't
capture just yet first Carlsen castles
the bishop is still on b6 so there is a
real no danger of Bishop d7 or something
like b5 to protect this pawn on c4 so we
have Bishop to d7 Bishop back to f4
again if you can recollect it now but if
Knight captures on c4 now Knight
captures Bishop captures and now h6
Bishop captures we have G captures on f6
and after Queen to b4 even f5 and after
you keep the White Queen back the black
moon will now be also very strong so
nothing for whites to look for here so
postponing the capture of the gambit
pawn for one more move Bishop to f4 and
here Corona goes Knight to g6 Knight to
g6 going after the bishop but there was
also a very interesting move Queen to c5
Queen to c5 either guarding the c4 pawn
because
the sea for ponies guarded twice and may
be threatening to the protected and even
keep it maybe white would have to
capture the night here and if I've
removed the defender of the c4 pawn and
but also in doing so give up the bishop
repair so for example the trip captures
Queen captures and only now will you
recapture Knight captures Quintus e7
putting the Queen on the same file as
the White Queen that is undefended and
c2 rook a to see one and here we would
have a very nice equally game so also
possible but Corona goes for a different
idea Knight to g6 and okay the bishop is
under attack on f4 you want to move at
the bush up to g3 and now comes the
bishop to c6 kuranes bishops are now
excellently placed this this and b6 this
and on this very strong diagonal on g2
but also this Bishop can come at c7 at
will Knight captures on c4 now capturing
and c4 is definitely the way to go push
up the c7 and now look after d1 it's
very hard to find a way to look for
advantage here for white other than to
immediately occupy the open D file it's
an open file and there are four roofs
that are simply waiting to use it not
perhaps not the most creative thing to
do but if you don't do it your opponent
will do it so rook to d1 we have rook F
to d8 and now we have an exchange of
ropes crossing places the other rook to
d1 and Carwin exchanges the other pair
of rooks as well rook captures Queen
captures and now comes the Knights to d5
offering even more trades Queen to d4
and now nice captures on c3 Queen
captures on c3 and now bushel captors
and g3 we have H captures on g3 and now
Queen to d7
caranas Queen now occupies the only open
file on the board and it's very
interesting how will cost and go about
this Carlson plays Bishop to d3
I mean the night on g6 but also in some
variations the bishop will be very
strong on this diagonal perhaps some
threats against the h7 phone can be made
in the future and there was a lot of
discussion here after this Bishop to d3
move
there is a one who move that really
allows black to to pose the problems for
white so it's actually Bishop to e4
point being that if you capture the
bishop rush of characters then Queens
the d1 will lead to a perpetual check
after King h2 queen h5 check King goes
back windy one check and here we would
have a draw by repetition but after this
Bishop to you for move white also has
the option of playing Knight to e5 and
here there are some lies that would be
possible for example if Knight captures
on e5 Queen captures now f5 which again
in an equal game it's hard to say if if
white could actually make something
happen after this f5 move but also after
Bishop three four ninety five you could
have this Queen d8 simply waiting to see
what happens and now after f3 keeping
the bishop back Bishop captures Knight
captures and we would again have this
endgame with a queen and the night
against the Queen and the night where
White's pawn structure is a bit you know
drafty in front of the White King but
I'm not sure this would be such a
disadvantage so all in all again even if
not going for the for the perpetual
would be an equal if endgame but okay
after Bishop to d3 b6 is played by
Khurana and now Carson plays f3 not
allowing any any tricks with giving up
the Bishop and then going for this
perpetual the diagonal closest and the
car across and shows that he is
definitely ready to play this out Bishop
to b7 not allowing any Knight d5 ideas
to come with an attack against the
bishop and the Queen and also preparing
Bishop to a6 in some lines Bishop
captures on g6 we have pawn captures and
now comes a four and a lot of people
were saying that this is definitely an
advantage for Carlsen because now it's a
queen and the night against a queen and
the bishop and a queen and the night
usually will have a lot more
coordination than a queen and the bishop
of course there are exceptions to this
rule but Crossman's plan is to push this
pawn all the way to e5 and to use the d6
square that is a dark square
as an outpost for his very strong
Knights even if the Queen's are
exchanged of the board here Quintus Issa
a very nice move by Caruana
that well eyes to exchange the Queen
also is attacking the g3 pawn and with
Bishop to e6 as this was a plan with
Bishop to b7 is threatening to exchange
Queens here we have if Queen thirty-one
not really anything to look forward to
as the Queen King can simply move back
and there are no more tricks here so
after this efore move Queen to c7 also
attacking the g3 pawn but here across
and simple plays d5 as planned he wants
to create a very nice outpost for his
Knight and d6 but also a very
interesting reply to Queen to c7 would
have been Queen to d4 which again comes
as a very strong line not Queen captures
and g3 is met with Queen to d8 check
King moves and now comes Knights the d6
attacking both the bishop on b7 and the
pawn on f7 and after Queen to e1 check
King to h2 now there's no perpetual here
because the h4 Square is covered by the
White Queen here now you would have to
play f6 so the White Queen is no longer
guarding the h4 square but now you're
also no longer in control of your Bishop
on b7 so now we would simply have Knight
captures and again we would have this
perpetual so a bit of a longer line but
Crossland doesn't go into it after Queen
to c7 he simply decides to push be v he
actually wants to trade the Queens of
the board and try to look for advantage
in a Night vs Bishop endgame Queens the
c5 check King to h2 and now comes the
bishop to h6 now as the knight is
attacked twice
you can either defend it would be three
or as the point so we'll get separated
there's really no point in doing so
simply nice to d6 immediately Queen
captures pawn captures on c3 and now
comes f6 trying to challenge this
outpost of the night and d6 cross and
simply protects it with f4 and King to
f8 Corona is now preparing to bring his
King into the game and cross and does
the same we have came to g1 King to e7
and now King to f2 we have King to d7
and now comes into e3 instead of King
- III an interesting option would have
been c4 but it doesn't do all that much
for now you can see that at the c4 pawn
and the knight to really control this
bishop on e6 the bishop really has
nowhere to go but after something like
captures captures and Kings to d6 a king
to c6 now you can approach with the
white king as well
King III g5 now and now King to f3 if
you go for the pawns on the Kings side
you will actually lose this endgame
because black will be much faster due to
due to having two points connected to
two pawns for example King attacks the C
pawn and now if you start collecting the
pawns and the King side black will
simply be much faster after those bones
start rolling down the board the black
pawn will Queen much faster
so after this g5 you will not be able to
go for the King's iPhone so rather you
will have to go 14 to d4 and now after
Bishop to b7 night he ate attacking the
g7 pawn upon g6 the night goes back a 5
and now you will be able to exchange
here and after a couple of exchanges you
will not be able to even push c5 here
because if you allow c5 and b5 then
black was the one black is the one who
will actually be winning but here you
can see that black has all of all of the
squares covered and the White King has
no way of even approaching at the
position so basically it would be a draw
so here Carlsen decides to go
immediately for King to e3 but now
Khurana simply attacks it with Bishop to
f1 the g2 point is under attack
cross and goes back to defended karana
simply repeats push up to a 6 we have
king to e3 Bishop to f1 and here cross
and makes his 40th move so basically he
did reach time control King to have to
he offered the draw here and a draw was
agreed upon
now before a Caruana even made his 40th
move but yeah
game 7 not not something good to be
proud of with the white pieces I guess I
mean it's hard to say not to be proud of
a draw against 2800 Plus opponent but
still it's very weird especially because
of this early moment in the
okay Carson did deviate from from Game
two after this after this Queen a5 he
deviated with Knights to d2 but then
Quinta dear it is a move that well I
have no idea for sure but you know if
you've listened to the press conference
it seems that he wasn't really prepared
for it so and as there are as there
aren't all that many replies black can
make Queen d8 should have been something
maybe
cousin cousin should have blissed his
response immediately out to do but again
it's hard to say there are so many
branches and so many supercomputer lines
that I guess it's you just don't expect
a move like Queen to d8 and obviously
Fabi was very much prepared for this
night the d2 deviation it's not like he
thought he obviously he didn't think
that cousin would actually prepare
something for the for the rook d8 line
but yeah
you know very exciting lines very
exciting times to be you know watching
these supercomputer preparation lines
and it will be very interesting to see
how the rest of this world's
championship match will unfold we have
five more games like we said Khurana
will be having the white pieces in three
more games and Carson will only have the
white pieces twice again is this a plus
for Carson is this a plus for Caruana
two years ago in New York against
kurakin cross and it was actually in
game eight that Carson tried it to push
too much and win a position that was
just unwinnable and Indian ended up
losing it so will Carlson managed to
just draw out all all the other games up
until game 12 and then finally go into
Rapids but what what will that mean for
chess I mean in New York we the world
the classic world chess championship was
decided in in faster time controls and
if we will here also have a decision
about who the next world chess champion
will be not in the classical classical
time control but rather in Rapids or
even Armageddon and
you know definitely or maybe they should
do something about about the the whole
approach to the classical world chess
championship it's quite strange or even
just make it like like it was before
you know if the Challenger doesn't at
least win a game or if the if the score
at the end of the match is not in his
favor then the champion keeps his title
I guess I don't know so perhaps he has
to prepare some sharper lines but I
don't I don't know if this will be a
good way to keep the classical time
format going so yeah but as always I'm
very interested in what are your
thoughts what do you think is this is
this going cousins way is this going
core one as a way we still have five
more games to go and a lot more is there
to happen I would like to thank Dan
Hanson Paul dargah Carmen Juarez
Gregory castle ring and Rory cope Rita
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
video see our thank all for watching and
I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content maybe even mix it up before the
next World Chess Championship game thank
you all and I will see you soon